hey everyone oh hi plenty resident
president evil again personal that's
what you said I heard you president jf
Knievel so I believe Mike I have both
masks which is that all of them second -
yeah I thank you I put one on I remember
putting one on the face it's been two
weeks since I last sat in this room with
you
it's amazing of you go into Europe
you're so cultured I stayed here in the
great soil of the United States of
America most of San Francisco is
landfill
depending where you live I mean it
depends on your perspective of like what
a landfill is because I'd say the
majority of the streets are like
landfill anyway let's think this through
Thanks I am here I know where I need to
go
it's the outdoor area but I don't
remember the quickest way to get there
well first off do you remember like what
putting the masks on those statues has
been doing yeah it releases the it's
like a body bag coffin coffin yes yeah
so I'm getting cremated I don't know
what those are
it's like it was like dangling and there
was blood coming out should I come out
which I leave this door well check your
inventory did you you don't need to
increment I got a gun I wouldn't bring
the I wouldn't bring the class with a
lighter there why you never know what
I'm gonna need one of those well you
know the path there is pretty much dom
be free like regular zombie free but
what if i just need a quick drink from
my flask
there you go I feel like you're not
taking me seriously
no anything a quick drink of lighter
fluid shot how much hand sanitizer when
she doesn't have anything left a drink
so I need to go down those stairs I
think and then just know you could you
could go that middle hallway to the
right of the safe room like dodging
zombies but yeah you might as well just
go you may as well go up and then into
the dining room back I think when I
leave there zombies there how's my life
should I bring um
maybe I should bring up bring something
bring something let's prep I would say
go up the stairs and back into the
dining room because okay so to get back
out there you need to go through that
painting door in the main right I could
bring my a I could bring an herb or I
can bring mixed herbs bring green herbs
the regular green one you'll be fine
we said that last time but remember what
happened last episode I'm hoping I died
obvious sneeze : did you taste the in
here we need a sneeze button continue
without me I'll sneeze in a second okay
you guys might OH
oh Lord I see him in the shadow I'm a
ninja so where is he no not no tell you
right probably what do I do I come from
can i dodge him good yeah you try like
why I let him round the car oh that was
a close one
bippity Boppity that's not what people
say
give me the zappity all right nope nope
yeah oh man I've lost my way and so
people say when they Dutch zombies I've
lost my way
no bippity Boppity Dinkin Flicka that's
what they say
so weird
right through the main hall mm-hmm you
say manhole man halt vinegar
communication leaves something to be
desired after two weeks of them I think
I recorded what happened was I expected
you had come back a much more cultured
after your said I'm jet-lagged I'm tired
and cranky yeah I'm hoping you die geez
not in real life in the game you're both
rude honestly how are you going
I forgot we put my mouth I'm already
lost I don't know
painting door right there you're going
out where those like it I want to go
outside
yeah member you came on the other side
of the crow gallery where you're doing
that painting there's multiple ways to
get outside yeah but this is the
quickest you want to go through the crow
gallery yeah you know that come at me
it's also been two weeks since I've
played so I feel a little rusty like
this is the kind of game because of you
need to understand the who the locations
and the puzzles and you need quick hand
movements not playing it for a while is
pretty dangerous yeah that's like what
was it doing all right there's a 68%
chance you're gonna survive this oh my
god all right here we go um I need to
said that one is no nose
all right no nose I got something for
you I'm gonna hope I don't have a nose
after you this smelly display of resin
evil stop
am I being insulting today I'm really
not that cranky I'm just tired I'm doing
the ones where there's nothing unusual
of a mask without her nose it was that
one yeah observing I wonder what's in
there wait do I have enough bullets I
feel like I didn't really talk to about
this with you cuz I didn't replenish my
gun magazines yeah but you've got a
shotgun
it'll be fine I could make this my
primary you could safety first Richards
assault shotgun okay and then
neum oh that is a mask wait which one
isn't a mouse is it this one wait yes
right mm-hmm God so confusing if you put
them on the wrong one do you die no it
just doesn't let you put him on there
the trap on the floor shut up your
shotgun Chelsea right actually though
before you that's actually helping to
sell the game no no it looks like Viggo
Mortensen from is he really fast
no Dinkin Flicka scratch me uno mas oh
shut up oh my god you're making this so
much worse oh yeah the way he got up he
was really good all right sweet you what
took one hit that wasn't bad sick
footwork Kobe Kobe Bryant we're like van
Helsing no that's not people don't say
that my catchphrase Jesus all right cool
that's Resident Evil you just beat it oh
I did it
shai examine his [ __ ] corpse mm-hmm no
there's nothing there I don't think oh
there's probably something in the thingy
mm-hmm
there is a switch press it yep there's
something here
stone and metal object yes that's it
there's got to be something else in here
the following inscription is carved into
the cell I didn't I didn't read it I
actually just skipped it an eye for an
eye a tooth for it okay wasn't there
there was a lion statue that had like
two yellow eyes or something that I
thought was about yeah you need you did
the blue one that got you shotgun shells
me the yellow one you don't have that
but your memory is working this that's
correct yeah it is you know what jet lag
feels like you know how [ __ ] that way
it's like my memory is working in ten
second increments or I have to
constantly remind myself what I'm doing
here like what just happened if you
would like I know where you have to go
but I'm trying to think if she's your
map I guess he'll examine the object to
in case oh yeah that's a good idea
thank you I forgot about examining the
object something that I should be doing
all the time oh I thought I uncovered
she's pulled it from behind someone's
here magician a magic artist stone and
metal object
alright so nothing there this might be
just like a you know what also it says
fine shouldn't I be it caution I didn't
even get hit it might have been because
it was like a swipe and not an actual
like grab oh I thought he got me he did
but maybe it's just like a glance oh I
should change I'm gonna change back to
my gun because I don't want to I don't
want to use too many of my shotgun you
know Chouard sweet
um a little kid idiot with his bow and
arrow it's just doing his best you know
this is interesting this is the kind of
thing where a game that could be done
really quickly takes forever because you
just walk around cuz you don't know what
to do that's what I'm gonna do because
an eye and a tooth for toy in reference
to any teeth or eye stuff that I know
about don't worry about that I don't
even know what that means I would just
say check your map to see where you
haven't gone yet okay or where you might
have gone your brain walks that seems
that seems smart you take too long I'll
tell you where to go but alright sure
that yeah all right so what key do I
currently I don't have any keys I'm out
of keys yeah that's your next thing I
think it's the helmet you need I thought
I could get I've gone in everywhere that
I could go I'm looking um there's this
red square there with a blue door which
means I can go in there that's something
it means I've been in there before
there's this one over here that has a
red door so that's the one that had the
Spencer family crest on it which is not
what you have oh I have a crest is that
what this thing is kind of yeah
don't in the middle object I don't know
what you'd call it that's some sort of
stone and metal object first I thought
it was like the top of a key but Oh like
it like you press the button extends
like that other one yeah unfortunately
no okay okay I haven't been oh I don't
think the beef you have been here but it
was really quick but you had you bailed
on the room really fast for a certain
reason I think I was like the third
episode cuz there was a zombunny that
makes sense
could have been dog related mm-hmm is it
outdoors
that outdoor area that I hate mm-hmm all
right so that's this way no not that one
hey how many outdoor areas there are I
was just in another outdoor area it's
not that one either no all right so it's
upstairs over here
no it's on the east side damn it well
okay just to start I would let's go to
the save room on the east side just
because oh you can come in that much
trouble
let's save just like four items because
you don't need I have everything I need
I would just recommend use your handgun
I would save the shotgun shells for like
really hard enemies now should I save no
cuz like you can kill that guy pretty
fast if you do died all right so which
same room should I go to should I just
go where where I was before no about the
East one you go up first and then down
you don't have to go through that dog
hallway actually the dog hallway at this
point might be nothing no there are a
few zombies there ya go down
what good day I'm sorry that's the the
broken door goat yeah you have to go
through here because the the other
doorway is do you remember my broken
doorway I lost one no actually yeah you
can use that through our way this time
you yelled at me for using the broken
door yeah you could use it now though
cuz it's about do whatever what you want
just go to that East save room
I've never had so many options before no
I really don't want to die I'll have one
of everything please
supersize all of it this one no that's
naked no I killed him
yeah that's why this thing he's super
dead alright so I'm going around
November he you thought you killed him
and then he ate Richard and you got a
shotgun and ran oh my god did you I was
gonna happen now
oh yeah that's what we need ah caught us
sleeping wakey-wakey
whoo I think that's the first time I've
been as surprised as you were jeez maybe
you just needed that dude sure to wake
me up yeah
I was like the kool-aid man oh just
broke through a door holy crap yeah your
skull I'm having a brain power yeah
you're like mentally oh I'm writing a
high still yeah good I mean you feel
free to bring your shotgun I would
definitely not recommend bringing all
your shells right cuz I want those
should I bring my lighter now and my I'm
a flash this is where I'm trying not to
I don't know how much to tell you and
how much then how much how much like
guys you want in terms of what items
bring so you don't get [ __ ] over right
right so I'm not to go through
everything again
all right here okay so don't worry about
the lighter you're basically going
somewhere that you're not gonna
backtrack to after you're done okay all
right so I'm gonna want
I'm gonna keep my herb because that's
always nice to have mmm I'm gonna keep
the stone a metal object I'm gonna keep
both weapons just in case okay so I
think I'm in mind you do still have the
regular shotgun which has six shells in
it which you can't just like take out of
it what do you mean so like I would
recommend bringing the regular shock and
then getting rid of this good one yeah
just so you use those six shells if you
need them okay cause you can't just like
unload it I don't think I mean you never
could before so alright I feel good well
the only thing I was thinking about was
saving no I wouldn't I really wouldn't
worry about saving it
what about whoa heard ring handgun ammo
as well all right you should have like
60 something I thought I did you do
somewhere oh no oh my god does that mean
I'm maxed out no you can go higher yeah
I think you go higher
very cool all right so okay the interest
of time I'm going outdoors you are going
outdoors I don't know if you remember if
you look at your map see this like the
curvy thing at the top to that room with
the two arrows coming out of em you went
out there before but then a dog attacked
you so you bailed because you were
pretty close to dying that's where
you're going though I'm out to kill that
dog
Yeah right but the regular shot gonna be
fine for that what do you mean I just
have my gun up you brought the regular
shotgun - I did should I equip it look a
bit when it comes time you can oh yeah
there's it's always time oh my god oh
sorry go down oh you're right sorry
alright so normally I would not condone
using this door if you don't have to but
yeah use it I still have one more which
means this is your last one but yeah
you're fine
no I have one more after this once you
open is gonna be broken oh I thought I
got one more after that no everything
you went back through it and then came
BRR I thought I'd got three oh you did
use three already shit-faced [ __ ] sorry
alright nevermind go back up in her
house go back to the main entrance hall
and then no cuz there's a crimson head
in there in that there's nothing in the
entrance hall it'll be faster to go
where and you don't mind yeah yeah
you're right you're right I'll shut up
what are you doing I feel like you're
telling me something it was in there
you're right I've misspoken you were
right so I did not get it this isn't
where they do this no this is upstairs
oh yeah it was I don't think was a
crimson header just a regular zombie I
could be wrong you can dodge him though
you've got a dagger two of them you've
got a few stun gun rounds - oh my god
charges I guess the proper term would be
I feel like I don't have that many I
only have four I thought by now oh it
isn't you can dodge that sure where is
he Oh Los Angeles dodging yeah yeah yeah
yeah bait him oh yeah
dumb dumb yours this woke me up
all right so so leaving mm-hmm oh my
goodness
huh it is hot in here that stressed me
out Eric was in here sweating he was
playing a game before I was had to kick
him out um okay so I heard he got
confused
I'm going downstairs and then to the
right and then back to the east yep a
few zombies poured into that hallway but
you don't have any other choice should I
kill them
this one right yeah I would dodge him
possibly the door wasn't even like
rattling before he busted through no you
just my god so am I just going into this
red hallway that you've got a bad one
with the dogs yeah there's one dog I
think they're they don't even like
notice you for the first two seconds so
you'll be fine all right way I'm just
planning ahead so I just take a left and
I go go go go go go mm-hmm all right
here we go
the music come on organs getting
creep-creep-creep the creeper II creep
creep creep creep oh that was bold you
went back to his strong side he has a
strong side he's left-handed I don't
think I don't think I love dogs are
equal on both sides
dogs are ambidextrous is that we were
trying to tell me okay
[ __ ] yeah you just got some dodging so
wait where am I going I'm going no big
deal I'm just going through great um yes
to that like to the end of the hall
lower case are shaped huh oh yeah oh
yeah just bring them in here and then
dodging you got more room behind you
yeah like in here there you go Oh
it's freaking angle though like it's
cool visually they make sure he walks
into this upper area thirsty Oh dumb hey
zombie by a zombie you got it no there's
three no you're good okay I can't see I
can't see I really can't see I can't dig
dig tunnels the angles change my
thoughts all day all right my speaks
Spanish when I'm scared
dumb face you can go behind actually but
go fast though because he's gonna do
that spin grab tele am I making it
stressful more stressful
woosh idiot good good what an idiot all
right so there's dogs out here and I
have to kill them at least one I'm gonna
kill them I hate dogs I hate dogs
no I crap I don't examiner
oh that's craftsmanship you [ __ ]
stay on target I see it shadow I think
that's a tree oh damn thank you Dad I
think so too
no you're the worst mmm it's a dog
shotgun shell and your stupid little
things I have them on caution I'm just
gonna eat this nice this sucks
use it before even got to the there's a
little baby with no wings angel baby
with no arms or wings it sound like a
Smashing Pumpkins son angel baby with no
arms or no wings Billy Corgan is weird
mm-hmm well looks y'all represent show
them be like I defiled that coffin it
looks similar
OOP what made a farting noise and you
put it in change the well that's somehow
less sinister than I thought it might be
I'm not scared anymore should I push it
or good heavy door they trying to keep
out try to keep in gimme gimme gimme
wait are those for the shotgun I have
currently are they all the same
yep I will take these but stop no no I'm
trying to help all right so don't man no
no don't do that don't do that because
you can potentially those six shotgun
shells you can use for this salt just
try to run out of the regular shotgun
you shouldn't even need the you know you
know I'm saying because you don't know
we're trying to deplete the ones in this
shotgun all right so there's this door
the first day it said I don't want to
write but isn't it down these stairs or
something yeah you know oh we get that
charge yeah I will take that you will
come back through here so don't feel
weird leaving stuff I thought you said I
would never come through this area again
there's two I mean yeah but you you're
gonna come back through here to get to
the mansion then you won't have to well
this area yeah bring it you'll come back
through this area I'm just saying party
are you going to I'm trying not to spoil
anything so there's two doors there's
this lower one mm-hmm and there's this
scary one yeah stop speaking Spanish
Kurt and don't speak Spanish um I was
gonna go down this one cuz it looks less
scary all right you got those shoulder
pads though you're fine that's not true
it's like Marisa Tomei and my cousin
Vinnie where are you [ __ ] dogs this
area so creepy I'm waiting for dogs just
for like a second well it's been an
entire episode here all right just only
one of us have has never been here
before
so let me be a little scared did that
come off as sarcastic sound like even
too tired doesn't sound sincere meri
you're really good at this game I'm
ignoring you
it seems to be some kind of signpost yes
each direction is accompanied by a
corresponding destination north valley
of destruction that sounds lovely cave
of hatred even but I hear it's great
this time of year commit of madness and
west the path of revenge I have a
layover at the summit of madness it's on
the way to Boston there's no this
doesn't work
luckily I have a compass don't I I had a
compass is it not working
Oh No
Barry
God guns ineffective against it
what's a forest isn't that where she is
I don't know where the forest is I'm
just in the middle of these like these
trees growing everywhere oh my god all
right I'm trying to lighten the mood now
you can't have it both ways
no I'm dealing with this on my own
oh this area is so cool-looking he's
telling me not to do this maybe I should
I don't have anywhere to go
I have no leads besides to do this
mm-hmm guns ineffective
I thought those we're doing it at first
but it's just one dog
the gate will open when the guard dogs
desires are fulfilled what do you want
me to do to them revenge I want you to
satisfy those dogs in this statue with
blue eyes
the last gasps of destruction I don't
know destroy them um I don't have any
items besides my guns forgot to your old
glamour muscle this is a puzzle I'm not
a puzzle somehow but didn't let me
rotate them uh-huh like Jill looked at
the camera when she discovered that this
is a puzzle this is a puzzle
I can't rotate them I can't do anything
as far as I'm aware
besides shoot them I should shoot them
there their eyes are red when I want
eyes when eyes blue right so
I feel like you're hinting at something
mm-hmm well I have the ones from the
lion that I know that was yellow yeah
the sound design here is really good as
a side note uh these are that's blue
mm-hmm that's red so with the red side
when the instruction red was destruction
no wait blue is hatred I thought one was
revenge [ __ ] you're right I have to read
them again blue is destruction red is
revenge red is revenge blue salutes
destruction red his revenge
that makes R&R yes okay
blue is destruction okay
it changes the way he's oh I see there's
it's changing the way he's facing mm-hmm
blue is destruction so what what what
direction is destruction
remember the layover joke we're making
there I made that brilliant joke I made
no I block out most of your joke Oh
remember like it yeah like summit of
destruction cave of hatred okay I need
to I need to look at them again that's a
good puzzle mm-hmm
okay blue is destructions blue north
blue north red west blue north red
West's GOOD stoppage he's mooning you it
was an accident
bleeeh north red right west wait chimney
up I got it
totally got it it's going so fast yeah
that like dexterity requirement I don't
think is the best part of the puzzle
keeps on your toes though I wonder if I
should have gone through those double
doors the wooden ones that looked really
scary I bet you it was locked and I
needed something I have to go back there
anyway shut up shut up shut up I stirred
that's right okay yeah don't waste ammo
just either I didn't I was like a whole
a second yeah no I dodge dodge that's a
new song who sings mr. Jones and me
dodging crows you are not you're tired
good I'm fine so that bird didn't hurt
me but I heard it I heard the chains did
you hear the chains yes way do me a
favor actually
all right this is one of those times
where I want you to go back just go back
but don't sprint that's what angers the
crows but there is something back there
you should really should get now okay as
opposed to like on the way back okay I
got it I'm gonna take my time slow and
calculated
right now what I know there's a walkway
down here no [ __ ] crows equals plus
equals oh [ __ ]
you can't get it yet [ __ ] no wait yes I
don't think you go to the right
forgot oh no it's fine you can get it
out there [ __ ] okay yeah you're good
nevermind just continue where you were
going you could probably run if you want
to just dodge the crows I need an item
yeah you have it it's just in your safe
box I forgot to tell you bring it that
windcrest you got from the bumblebee
lure room I'm running it's okay everyone
knows crows can't pass gates Becky it
doesn't look like it's working anymore
they're too stupid I hear that I heard
the change now the gates fine what the
[ __ ] I feel like I should know I have
spray take my time
you can walk faster no I'm in no rush I
disagree
can't wait to meet 2 Chainz leave the
jokes to me Mary
where is he day me how do you do this to
me
yep you're the pro you've seen the
Exorcist that's what I was quoting I
hate that movie no no it's my favorite
movie you tell me all the time I'll
watch it soon we should return to a
mansion so to speak I'm getting confused
this kind of this seems like the kind of
thing that I'm gonna have to backtrack
at it really fast and I'm not gonna
remember all the twists and turns I have
to make it's how I feel huh like it's
pretty much a straight past it's kind of
a path it's kind of deceiving you you'll
be fine
limbo was like that like it would take
you in this weird path and then it would
make you redo the path really quickly or
you'd be dead it was so scary it was
really good
laughter okay here we go oh this this
pleasant-looking shack i love puddles
yeah there'll be fun if you stepped in
it was really like 10 feet deep this is
the only enjoyment I'm gonna get goddamn
imagine trying to like swim out of like
a hole 10 feet deep filled with water
that's like just big enough for you to
even fit down imagine trying to wiggle
your way out like oh man oh man okay I'm
going in to go in this door do it should
I take one planter no I got I got no I'm
good
we go what's in here I love how like
light that door sounds yeah that sounds
nice what is that by my feet what is
that your roots I think growing up from
the ground I know like you I don't like
it what is that what are these balls on
the wall why is there fire pumpkins huh
another garlic me avoid
this fire looks fresh zombies can't
light fires zombies can't vacuum carpets
but there's a vacuum cleaner right there
a number of bandages have been hung up
could these brown stains be blood map
there's a map of the courtyard das cool
I found a lot more stew looking all this
is red because I've so yeah you remember
like those tombstones you couldn't do
anything with it right oh god oh god
a crude bed that's weird
Oh a safe point where it up a family
photo
my daddy attached first mom attached
second inside red and slimy white and
hard not true mom where what persons
trying to write smut and failing dead no
dad mom found mom again when attached
mom my she moved no more she screaming I
just want to be with her
sounds like a wrap mom where I miss yo
you Oh weird
Oh God a safe box I can save em hmm and
this means wait where's the music should
this be a safe area with a little safe
music maybe they know that throwing
convention away what's gonna scare you
can I save ya before you forget God the
windcrest - oh right I did four yet yeah
I don't know why I said before should I
do the windcrest and then save No
you just gave something away I'm a
genius
I'm a species Holman I'm smart okay so
save save ribbons go away mm-hmm I'm
gonna keep everything else that gives me
two slots now would get rid of shotgun
shells really cha you really want me to
have any shotgun what's in here oh is
that okay I can't go any further
hey you can press X it's a good doorway
kind of oh that's misleading mm-hmm
that's another one of those moments that
like I would have gone I wouldn't have I
wouldn't got it oops yeah yeah I am I'm
gonna turn those I'm not plan that I'm
gonna I'm gonna turn those up after this
episode let's see if he keeps talking
who's heute a huge friend Hugh is this
the reason that I talk to you online
oh nice person I will take that crank
this is the outhouse this is where the
poop happens all right I don't see
anything else ever hear people have
nightmares that they get buried alive
slowly at the bottom of outhouses
no that doesn't happen doesn't well I
would hope it doesn't happen but it's a
nightmare people have I saw a movie
where a guy had to hear that oh no did
you hear that I actually can what the
[ __ ] is happening I can't hide Mary what
the [ __ ] is happening there's a guy in
the house no there's not
just go I am a pansy
ooh yeah you [ __ ] up I [ __ ] up I
should have told you no just kidding
you're fine jeez I saved Mike it's rude
that's camera angle back I got hit by a
zombie or something uh oh my god yeah
yeah yeah I would run
I can't this is upstairs oh yeah it was
like just bader hurt yeah really good
beating her I can't see [ __ ] how am I
gonna get ran run nice let's go
somewhere yeah wouldn't where you got
some distance oh she's going faster oh
she's going faster Todd oh my god you
hit a pear pad of her footsteps she's
getting faster okay you got herbs out
here too right she needs one of those I
should give her one of those herbs she's
got a bunch of weird stuff going on with
her body yeah what if she's like Mischa
Barton from sixth sense so I'm just
gonna take it and eat it
she just needs help cuz then I have I
have the spray still if I need it that
makes sense mmm-hmm spray does to health
cracks believe so now I can take two
more hits mm-hmm
I would take that green herb but I have
the spray oh you're saying I'm not gonna
come back here correct let's check I
have
oh it's green that means I don't have to
be back here anymore well you're not
gonna get any yeah for now
I [ __ ] heard that
I heard it I heard it yeah that's a
zombie you're gonna hear a lot of them
these [ __ ] camera angles suck she
shoot him
no you can go uh no keep going the right
here's going oh my god you can go around
that tree to the right oh I got him is
there any more nicer
it's going well it's shut up
it's the impending doom of the crows
that I hate so much or like of that
noises like the zombies making that
noise mmm once I see him I feel like a
little bit of relief but just hearing
him and knowing that he's out there it's
just horrible
it's the anticipation not the actual act
that's correct okay
Oh oh no I'm out of thingies just use
that green herb I don't need it
I know but oh wait no no sorry sorry
sorry okay no cuz I can't I put it on
one at a time yes you're correct Mike
you Dom mm-hmm you funny but you stupid
okay
all right so wait how many I had star
moon and what else star Moon and Sun
when you come in home
oh wait I [ __ ] up look at how [ __ ]
smug that son is he's my need to know
some as text symbols at this point two
vertical lines across and three
horizontal lines I mean looks like a
magnet I'm a genius with that [ __ ] on
your fridge
I will two vertical lines what
but
what do you mean I could examine it like
actually press X when your exam okay
that makes it
frickin dumb I already solved it with my
brain okay merely hold my god
sorry I didn't mean to do that most
crows do not sound happy eating or
something I tell you when I went to
Australia like on my first night there
koalas outside my door and I could hear
them mating at night and they were
making noises like I'll keep doing this
like this I didn't know you were a liar
that's the noises they make when they're
mating that's the noise I would make up
if I had never been to Australia know
that what happened
that's also the animal I would pick like
Oh a kangaroo mugged me took my ten
dollar dad what kind what currency they
use I'm serious
Australian dollars Oh hmm look look at
it Oh beautiful take a look at that I
will things things almost too big to fit
on the screen
you shouldn't take it yeah you're good
can I shoot this crazy no you can't have
it done what if that woman with all the
lumps on her back but slowly
walkie-talkie follows yeah he's like
gagging like dry heaving yeah
cool that's like a whole area it's
checking out my mappy I got this whole
area done
yes boppity boop it's not it baby boo
bippity Boppity bop bop ba-bop give me
the zappity bops on parade Rage Against
the Machine alright I think that's good
I think that's that's rad we did it good
job nice I should say yeah should we go
in here yeah I hadn't saved in a while
hey did you save them to Lisa's house
that was Lisa by the way I don't think
that's the one who has a name that was
why the letter saying like Jorge Trevor
and mom and dad are attached and [ __ ]
and like white and hard red and slimy
well Brad Jill to Brad can you hear me
[ __ ] broken well that wasn't helpful no
on the next episode of resident knievel
the end of the episode it's been about
45 minutes yeah okay cool thank you guys
for watching don't forget to Like and
subscribe
yeah that dogs not done with you yeah
[ __ ] your outro the dog says how do you
know he's dead I wouldn't
yes
subscribe this I thought it was a safe
space nope no no there are no safe
spaces dog was
did really not want to like comment
subscribe sweet on the next episode with
the conclusion the penultimate episode
we conclude this series oh my god I was
really good